Alright
Umm
Try to climb that tree, dude.
Hyeah
Oh wait hang on
Tyler: URRRAAGGH
Tyler: *gasp*
Do it again!
Hang on-
Wait-
Yeahhh
Yeahh hu-Oh
This is SO sick
I got it, I GOT it dude
I got it, YEAH
Tyler: Your turn
Alright, I'll do it
Alright
EGGHH
*gasp*
*sigh*
*sniff*
umm
I'm just gonna jump
And we'll cut it together to look like I did it, okay?
Tyler: Okay.
Alright, okay.
That'll do right?
Tyler: You gotta get the other foot off the ground.
It was off the ground!
No it wasn't!
Tyler: I got it!
Okay cool alright yeah
Got that
Yeah man! *WHUPSHH*
I'munna- I'munna.. hurdle over that bench
Are the settings right?
Tyler: Yeah
Okay.
Am I in shot?
Tyler: Yeah
Alright
Tyler: Get it!
Tyler: (louder) get it!
Tyler: heyeheheaaah!
Tyler: Yeaaaahh!
You got that, right?
Tyler: Don't, don't, shhh, geugh- I gotta- eeer-
Tyler: I don't want you hurt on camera
HUGGHH
HEGGGHH
merr
Yeah, leap over me!
This is gonna be good
HEH
That was SO sick, dude
That was so sick
ULAGGGHHLEE
Tyler: uhhuhehuhuhAAAuh
ehuehuehu
I think I got it
Tyler: yeah
Fu- uh... uh-uh-uh
Dude, get this!
get this-
get-
Tyler: Dude!
Tyler: (higher pitch) dude!
I got it, i got it!
Tyler: Looks good.
Okay
I look good
Tyler: hehyeaaaaaah!
Tyler: what, I didn't look at your ass
MURPH
Alright come on.
What are you- s-
Jesus Ch-rist!
UGHH
I play games for a living, I can't run!
HUGHH
HUHH
HUGGHH
*Heavy breathing*
Tyler: MOO
Okay, do the thing
He's using the thing...
HUHH
Yeah, yeah that's-
That's good
*ching ting*
I bet I could bench that
Tyler: do it!
Yeah man!
Dloolaaaaghhhghh
Tyler: wheezing sound
UlllluuughhhhHEH
Bluaeughhhhh
Tyler: Oh my god, no!
No- Wait- Okay-
Do it!
Nice!
Tyler: You should caber toss it
OHHH
Hell yeah!
Dude I caber toss myself every night!
........
This isn't illegal, is it?
Tyler: uhhh-
Is this illegal?
Tyler: Hey- you know what would be really cool?
Tyler: If you threw it OVER me.
...OUH-
K you got it, it's rolling? (Yep)
UGHHH
Tyler: ohh my- OW!
Tyler: ohhh...
Tyler: ohhoh
Dude- is the camera okay?!
Is the camera okay?
Tyler: You BROKE it over me!
What?!
Tyler: You broke it over me!
Tyler: Look at this!
I think it was like that
Oh my god
BEEEEES
BEEEES
Uhh bee- UUUHHPP
Duuude! What the hell, man!
Fuckin' bees, dude!
They swarm at like, a moment's notice.
Dude, I think it's a condom.
Tyler: NEHEEHEER
EHEEHEUUHUUHUUUHUU
Tyler: NYAGGGH
Ehuhuehuehue
Is it dead?
You can talk to me, you know?
If you need to...
Tyler: Nope.
Do I look good? Good right?
Tyler: Yup
Sah dude!
Markiplier- no
SAAAAHHH dude! Eauh
I'm like 27 years old, I can't do that
SUAH
SUAHH
SAH
Sahh dude.
I'm here with my main man, Tyler.
He's gonna be helping me make the BEST quality videos from now on
We're gonna be goin' out
We're gonna be doin' sick flips
Uhhhhh
De-auuugh
Barkour, we're gonna be doin' a lot of that
uhhhh
uhhhhhh
uhhhhhhh
Just do it again, hang on I gotta do it again.
SAAAHH DUUde
Nah, I don't like that.
You do it, hang on
I wanna see you do it, and then
Go for it
Tyler: Sahh duuuude!
Man, you do it so good!
I'm not good at that!
Tyler: Suuhhh duude!
I'm here.
(Music cuts in and out then sounds evil)
AUUUUUEEEUUUEUUGH